Just trying to recall anything.
Hello.
Hi.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the flashlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on
the link for the flashlight and enter in
the code name Brogan,
you will get 15% off the
number one sex toy from men.
Clean it.
Don't forget to wash it out.
Don't forget to wash it.
So this is what's going on folks.
We're sitting here around waiting
for Graham Hancock to get here.
He was doing some sort of
a seminar in Orange County.
And so,
uh,
that's like at least an hour away.
So don't get an I instead of just
sitting here staring at each other,
decided to stare at each other online.
So that is the,
that's the,
um,
the basic motivation for this podcast.
Yup.
I ended up by getting out here.
It's crazy,
man.
I ended up in some,
my gps took me in a bad direction as time.
You're out in the middle and nowhere,
man,
I ended up
okay
in a place that was like
the surface of the moon.
I don't know where the fuck it was.
Spooky.
It was spooky.
Like I could have gone off a cliff and
no one would have found me for a week.
He'd be fine too.
Don't worry about it.
You're tweaking.
Stop.
You're tweaking,
son.
We're tweaking bro.
You scared of nature tariff.
Now I'm not scared of nature,
but I am scared at night when I'm,
when you're going around like
winding curves through math country,
I'm not exactly like exactly comfortable
those Carly's lives out there.
This is a lot of people live out there,
but my window space,
they like to be away from each other.
I like space.
Why do people assume that?
But there's a strange thing why people
assume that when someone wants to be a
way that they want the want
some space between you and them,
there's something creepy about him all
day and you're out there and fucking
cooking math and you know,
you're automatically assume.
Why is that cabin by itself?
Would that chimney blowing smoke?
What the fuck are they cooking in there?
Yeah.
You know,
you don't look at it
and go look at that guy.
He's out there just doing it by himself.
Chopping Wood.
No.
Yes.
Assume automatically that some creepy
thing is going on out there and if he's by
himself,
when traditionally they're creepy people
are the ones who live underneath you on
your apartment.
There was a real creep.
So once you're masturbating
to your footsteps,
but step fetish,
yes,
there was a documentary,
you know that,
um,
vbs.tv.
You know what I'm saying?
The,
I wouldn't call it a documentary,
I guess I'd call it a a,
an episode where they went and they went
and visited this guy who lives in like
northern eastern Alaska.
He lives like way the fuck up there.
They have to drop him off supplies and
he lives in this little tiny shack and
he's like one of the few people
that's allowed to live there.
And he's been there for like 20 years.
This dude never even saw nine 11.
He never saw the towers go down.
He'd like heard that
something had happened.
He's so removed from everything.
He's got like a little generated.
It's sometimes he powers up a TV,
but,
and he's got movies that they watch.
But dude,
this guy's living in the woods in a tiny
one room house with his wife who looks
like some sort of an Eskimo,
you know,
type of woman and uh,
they're fucking happy shit up there.
He says that hunting and gathering,
it's like what keeps you
happy and that's what,
what keeps him happy.
He's out there shooting
Caribou and following them.
I mean,
it's fucking,
dude loves it.
He loves living up there.
It sounds great that he had a shoot a
bear on one of the episodes because the
bear had came too close to his house
and the bear bear's killed her dogs and
shit.
So it's the middle of the night.
They're running after this guy with a
camera and he's running through the woods
with a fucking shotgun and a boom,
boom.
He just blowing holes into this fucking
bear and chasing it down while they're
all chasing after him with cameras in
the middle of the night in the woods in
Alaska.
Dude,
it's gnarly.
It's,
it's,
it's a,
it's amazing footage too.
It's a,
it's such an interesting
insight to someone who would
choose to live that life.
You know,
which seems so horrifying to us.
But to him like our life
is just fucking mundane.
There's nothing to it.
You just can't get excited.
I don't think it's horrifying.
I,
I think it sounds amazing.
I mean there's something about being self
sufficient that seems like it feels so
incredibly good to be
completely off the grid.
And now that if the,
if everything fell apart,
your life would barely shift at all.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
Right?
But that's like,
is that like instincts
to not join the system?
I mean,
is that what that is?
Is that some sort of a
resistance of the hive,
you know,
that would feel good to
not need all these people,
you know?
Isn't that ridiculous?
Because the reason why
everything is so awesome,
the reason why society in general so
awesome is because millions of people
contributed to make this one colossal
thing that relies on millions of people.
But it,
but because all these
other people are involved,
it's fucking awesome.
It's amazing.
It's got some terrible parts about it too.
But the idea itself and what
can be accomplished with it,
it's fucking amazing.
So why do we want to not need that?
Why do we want,
do we want to keep the option open to be
a cunt so you can just fucking fuck off
and just going to go live off
Caribou in the middle of nowhere?
Well that's that.
That's like the argument.
You know,
like people have that
argument against monks.
Like when someone goes and becomes a monk,
it's the same argument.
It's like,
what are you doing?
You're ignoring all of society
to go and do and be a monk.
Isn't it better to be in the world
than it is to go and isolate yourself?
How if you do go and
isolate yourself or you,
so whatever you learn,
you're still,
it's not applicable to
people in the world,
but some monks,
I don't think they give a shit.
I,
you know,
some people they just don't care.
They're,
they're not concerned with the society.
They don't,
it doesn't make any difference to them
whether they're contributing or not.
Like who cares?
Yeah,
I hear you man.
I know what you're saying.
I've had that thought
in my head about monks.
You know,
like,
like what,
what,
what kind of a loser?
Just where's the fucking orange robe
and never beats off and just hides and
chance all day.
Like,
dude,
you're missing out on muscle cars.
Blow jobs,
great movies.
We'd Khakis.
Um,
you know,
you're,
you're missing out on killer restaurants.
You mentioned down on shit talking.
It's like you're missing
out on astral projection.
You can't send your spirit to the higher
dimensional planes to communicate with
the supreme gods or
third eye's sealed shut.
You have no idea about the,
what it feels like to be completely in
tune vibrating with the harmony of the
universe.
You're just,
you're just humping your leg humping down
there and the city while I'm floating
around the eternal paradise,
uh,
outside of time and space and
then like here or transcend them.
Bliss.
Do you think there's a monk
who could talk that good shit?
If there a model that you talk like that,
say things like that,
that guy should like be doing tours,
you know,
he would recruit monks
like left and right.
You can change the world.
If a guy could speak that
way about being a monk?
Yeah,
well they,
they,
uh,
I think what theoretically,
what may happen is that as,
as you evolve and begin to
like open your or is up,
and this is purely theoretical,
but I think that you begin to
extinguish the desire to eat,
to tour.
You extinguish the desire to do,
to,
to perform.
You don't want to do that anymore.
You're just kind of in another place
all together you've zoomed out.
It's like Google maps use
zoom so far out that year.
So you're saying that the more you
would go down the road of meditation,
the less you would want to do
standup comedy or you're saying,
is that what you mean by tour?
Yeah,
well,
no.
Yeah,
I mean like the show,
like the uh,
exhibitionism,
you know,
like the,
the for you were saying somebody you talk
like that she should tour and talk to
people.
Oh,
I'm saying someone who talks like that,
you know,
and it's all a theory.
It's an all,
it's a theoretical idea.
But,
uh,
the,
you know,
the assumption when someone becomes
a renunciate I think is that they're,
they're not,
they're not experiencing happiness.
Right,
right.
When it may be that the thing
that they're experiencing,
it's a million times better than what
they were experiencing in the world.
Well,
I know for a fact that I have achieved
at least bizarre states of consciousness
just from,
from yoga.
I,
uh,
I remember one time,
I was in New York and I was real nervous.
I had to do,
uh,
the Howard stern show the next day.
It was first time I
ever did it and no one,
I was genuinely nervous
and I couldn't sleep.
So it was in my hotel room reading off
of this ancient yoga book and doing these
poses.
And I did yoga for like
an hour and a half.
And at the end of it I felt fucking great.
I mean,
I didn't just feel great.
I felt high.
I felt,
frankly,
my body was like,
I felt team goals,
like a glowing tingle.
I mean,
I did this intense yoga
routine for an hour and a half.
And when it was over,
my body had just stretch everything out,
released,
all the tension opened up,
all the,
the,
the whatever the fuck it is.
You want to call it shock rose.
You want to call it senses,
you want to call it,
you know,
your,
whatever.
Your ability to tune in to
what's around you was all,
it was just cranked to 10 and I was like,
wow,
if this was a drug of this feeling
like an intense yoga workout,
you know,
it can feel very much
like a real mild pot,
you know,
like Whoa,
like nothing.
Nothing that's going to make you fucking
drive shitty or forget your keys.
But sometimes it's going
to make you just a little,
just a,
wow.
I feel a little better.
I feel a little more relaxed.
I feel a little sensitive.
I feel,
I feel good.
Yeah.
Well that's a,
you know,
that company that's,
I felt that too from yoga and I felt that
from chanting and I felt that from any
kind of ritualistic thing that has,
you know,
a spiritual undertones to it,
which I think yoga does.
Okay.
You got deep into chanting,
right,
didn't you?
You got at one point in time you were,
you know,
you,
you like,
you can chant out that fucking crazy.
I got deep into it.
What is that thing that you,
you busted out?
Bad thing is that,
that's a Hari Krishna prayer.
That's a prayer that you read before
that you say before you're going to read
the Bhagavad Gita and it means,
are you Christians read the Bhagavad Gita?
Oh yeah.
That's our primary text.
That and the stream on bog of a time.
Whoa.
But the,
yeah,
you say that prayer.
Um,
and they have a bunch of other texts too.
I mean,
they're really,
that's how they spend most of
their time is studying the Vedas.
Yeah.
So there know almost nothing about the
Hari Krishna is all I know that when,
uh,
when I was a kid,
people made fun of the Hari Krishna,
so it was like a stock joke.
Oh,
sure.
Oh.
And in movies to an airplane.
And so many movies they get made fun of
because they would go and hang out at
the airports.
And then these guys in saffron
robes with shaved heads,
right?
So it's like he,
we try to sell books,
right?
Yeah.
They tried to,
they tried to sell books and so there's
a lot of reasons that they did get made
fun of.
And it was like,
for me,
what happened to me was,
um,
well there's also a
bunch of legal cases too,
right?
Weren't there like real life scenarios?
Oh yeah.
It's organized religion,
man.
And,
and it's hardcore organized
religion that recommends,
um,
you know,
renouncing the world.
Like it,
it,
it doesn't tip toe around the fact,
like it's hardcore into the idea that the,
uh,
the way to live if you
really want to be happy,
is to let go of all the things
of the world and start chanting,
uh,
the Hari Krishna Maha Mantra and the,
the,
um,
uh,
but it's very important to realize that
that mantra is not owned by Iskcon,
which is the Hari Krishna is,
that's like the Catholic Church
for this sect of Hinduism,
um,
which is known Bhakti Yoga.
So there's a lot of different
schools of thought in it.
And it's a very deep philosophy that
has its roots in the idea that there is,
um,
that God,
everything comes from God.
And so the word Krishna means translates
into the reservoir of all pleasure.
So it's the idea is like all pleasure,
all opulence,
all happiness,
everything springs from some source,
like the big bang except
the spiritual big bang.
And this is that they believe that this
is an intelligent force in the universe
that has specific qualities.
And so people are kind of born with this
case of Amnesia where they've forgotten
that this even exists.
And so they begin to become attracted
to these qualities and different things.
So people are attracted to beauty,
people are attracted to intelligence,
people are attracted to wealth,
people are attracted to um,
strength.
But they say that these
are just the sort of the,
uh,
what people are seeing as the qualities
of the supreme being reflected through
the material universe.
And that's what people are attracted to.
And so by the specific
process of Bhakti Yoga,
you begin to turn your,
uh,
your senses back towards the original
source of all this stuff through this
very,
very strict discipline of
chanting not eating meat.
Um,
they recommend the,
the monks that where the rubs,
it's called the four
regulative principles.
So you don't eat meat,
you don't use any intoxicants,
no sex and no gambling.
You wake up at four every morning,
four 30 every morning.
You chant I think 16
rounds of this mantra,
Hari Krishna,
Krishna,
Yada,
Yada.
It all mounted on Ron,
Ron Manati and you study and you will
live in a temple and that's how you spend
your life.
And that's like a,
and you're still in the Bhagavad Gita.
You're studying the Vedas,
the Bhagavad Gita,
and the Shreem ABOG of a Tom and
all these other religious texts.
And you get deep,
deep,
deep into it,
to the point where you complete,
I mean they were recommend in,
as I recall there,
it's like your fee,
even your family,
your family is just a,
your is your Karma,
your fan,
like your attachment to your family.
It's just your Karma.
It's like,
let go of all those attachments,
surrender to this higher force and
then you'll experience transcend the
happiness.
And the ultimate goal in life
is to try to connect with God.
That's the only reason to be alive.
And if you're not
engaged in that activity,
then you're miserable.
Then you're not really experiencing
the type of happiness that,
and even if you think you're
experiencing happiness,
it's nothing compared to what
you can obtain from a living,
a spiritual life and chanting this
mantra and what happened to me.
But this is what you are
not saying is your opinion.
You're saying
this is what,
no,
that's not,
you know,
it's a summary of,
of it.
It's not my opinion,
but what happened to me,
you're saying it like almost
like in the first person,
like Oh yeah,
that,
I mean,
yeah,
I'm just explaining it.
I mean I'm a,
I don't really believe that though,
right?
No,
I mean I'm a comedian.
I was like just smoking in front
of the House of Blues Drunk.
I'm not,
I'm not like,
have you ever considered that?
Maybe that would be a path that you would,
you would get so interested in it
because you are interested in all those
principles you are interested in.
Well yeah,
I'll tell you your
consciousness and truth.
Have you ever thought about
doing something like join?
Well,
what happened was,
uh,
when I got into the heart,
when I got into the Hari Krishna
is what happened to me was,
um,
cause you know when you haven't,
if you haven't an experience,
you've had an experience.
There's no way around it.
If you have an experience,
you have to accept that the experience
happened and you have to tell the truth
about the experience one way or the other.
Right.
So for me to not talk about the,
you know,
that part of my life or
to pretend that I wasn't,
I had a conversion experience
where I was in this temple on,
um,
John Maass to meet,
which is,
uh,
the,
they call the appearance date of Krishna.
It's like Christmas basically.
And
what I was,
what did just happen before that is I,
someone had gotten me really high,
like really stunned.
So I was sitting in the,
in the temple and they're like ringing
bells and they have these like deities
that they were shipped
and they're pouring this,
uh,
I believe they pour like milk on the
deities and it's like there's this,
it's all your senses are being uh,
overwhelmed.
They're burning incense,
they've got like the flowers everywhere.
So the whole place just
garlands of flowers.
So it's just the smell of
flowers and incense and monks,
you know,
like the guys with shaved heads and then
necklaces that they wear and like bells
ringing.
So your senses are completely overcome.
And I've never had this
experience before or since,
but I was looking at these symbols
and all of a sudden assembles.
It felt like I was seeing past the symbols
into something deeper than what those
symbols were.
The symbols were just a human's attempt
to try to embody this greater thing that
exists in the universe.
And all of a sudden I felt the only way
I can explain it is it felt like I was
sound so crazy.
It felt like I was on a spaceship.
I thought,
oh,
this is like an advance.
This is what an advanced
intelligence is like this.
It felt like I was looking at something
that was a billion times smarter than I
was,
and that it was being somehow tuned
into and this ritual that if you were
outside the ritual or just look like
a lot of pomp and maybe some brainwash
people,
uh,
you know,
going through the motions of something.
But in the inside of it,
it felt like this incredible
blast of super intelligence.
And that happened to me and I like it.
It changed me for mine,
for the rest of my life.
I'll be changed because of that.
Like I'll never be the same after that.
What do you think it was?
Do you think it was a
combination of anxiety?
Because all these people are there
and do what you said you were.
Hi.
Yes.
What were you high on?
Marijuana g eat it or smoking it?
Smoked it.
What do you think it was?
What do you mean?
What do you attribute this?
I mean,
that's a pretty crazy
experience you're talking about.
Well,
I mean what I think that,
uh,
what it was the chance.
Yeah,
it's the chant.
I mean,
if you chant Hari,
the thing about Hari Krishna is you don't
have to be a Om Hari Krishna to Chant
Hari Krishna.
And that's,
that's the thing that they always said a,
the thing that,
uh,
prob apart,
the founder of the art Christian
has said is just Janet,
you have nothing to lose.
Chanted.
What the fuck does it do you?
You're saying this specific sin
synchronized series of sounds,
this chant,
how's,
has an effect that actually
puts you in a psychedelic state?
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
That's why I was like,
that's why all the hippies loved it,
man.
I mean,
yeah,
totally.
You,
it's,
Oh,
think of yoga.
Yoga is a,
um,
you know,
specific movements that you do
that if you do these movements,
you go into like what you said,
this mild psychedelic state.
Well that's just one form of Hatha Yoga
or whatever particular type of yoga you
are doing.
But in the same way the,
these mantras that they have,
um,
induce a very specific experience that,
if you do it enough,
you will,
it'll light.
The only way to explain it is it will,
your mood will lighten.
You will,
um,
the heavy,
you know,
that heaviness man.
I mean,
I,
there's a heaviness that people get that
I get and if I'm deeply in this state
that it's what I consider,
like the road rage state,
you know what I mean?
Where I'm likely to scream in a car,
cutting me off or something.
Like,
if you chant Hari Krishna
or any of the other,
there's a lot of other mantras out there,
uh,
then,
and you do it regularly just for a week,
then you will experience a
change in your consciousness.
Um,
early all isn't,
how are you attributing that mean?
What,
what,
what could possibly be?
I mean,
from a scientific standpoint,
see,
let's look at the scientific,
let's look,
go to scientists might say,
I think as scientists would say,
well,
it's a placebo effect.
You know,
you can,
you could decide to chant any mantra.
You can make anything up.
You could chant around Ddo Ddo Ddo if you
want it to and do that enough times if
you believe it,
it's going to be the
intention creates the change.
That's the,
that would be the scientific
explanation of it.
At the,
um,
the religious explanation of it is
that what you're doing is create your,
tuning yourself in to a specific,
you're tuning your neurology and when
you're chanting your addressing the
language center of your brain,
you're focusing in on
the specific pattern,
how they Krishnamurti Krishna,
Krishna,
Yada,
Yada at all.
Not at all.
My Rama,
Rama,
Hada Yachty and you do it
a certain way to do it.
How you do it,
how they Krishna,
Hari Krishna,
Krishna,
Krishna Yada Yada Yada.
You would do it if this is how I channel,
if I'm alone by myself and chanting,
I chant fast.
So it's like how do you son Niggas Niggas,
Niggas,
niggers [inaudible] goes down,
it goes down.
Well what Brahm does it talked about
this and said that it's like kind of the
way you,
Chan is just an indication of the,
where you,
where you are in life.
You know like,
so if I'm more relaxed,
the Channing will slow down.
But because of,
because of like,
because it's just the way I am.
Like I ended up changing fast
and I'll try to slow myself down,
but it just ends up going fast again.
But if you look at,
I mean I just was watching a video
of private by chanting and he chants
relatively fast so it
creates a sound like here,
listen Hoodie.
It creates this weird trippy sound,
especially when you're,
if you're do like for real intentions,
how'd he get shot?
He goes to negotiate negotiation.
I gotta get it on it.
On my momma.
You gotta get a good shot.
Niggas Niggas
[inaudible]
when I got to get it,
Christianity goes Nigga,
this Nigga,
I got it.
[inaudible] I'm Ron,
Ron
[inaudible] Niggas niggas zoning.
Let me get [inaudible]
Niggas Niggas only got it.
Yeah.
Put It on Monday.
[inaudible]
that's easily the weirdest.
She only
plus that out like that.
That's awesome.
That's the chat now.
But what's cool about it is you,
if you listen to the chant,
it has the own minute.
How'd he goes?
Yo Niggas Niggas niggas not.
I got to get it home.
Rum,
rum and some people will just chant the
arm or some people will just chat rom.
That's another chant.
Okay.
Rom Rom,
rum,
all of these are,
no matter what you think.
And I know people are
gonna think I'm an a,
you know,
a new age freak or whatever.
Um,
but I'm not,
I'm just telling the truth.
It's helped me immensely in my life.
I don't think anyone should do anything
more than like what they're comfortable
with.
But if you're having a bad trip,
if you're freaking out
in your life and your,
but if you,
especially if you're having a shitty
trip and you start chanting Hari Krishna,
you will feel better in every time.
Man.
If you could remember how it goes,
blitzkrieg daddy or a man talking to
the lucky charms guy at the top of the
world.
I'm not going to remember that.
Chris.
Dan,
could you that it goes down
when a woman just do the home?
Well,
I get super banked and getting the tank.
I,
um,
yeah,
cause you've,
when you're in the tank,
you know,
first of all,
it's a,
mine is very tall.
It's like seven feet tall and there's
a sound when your ears are underwater.
That's really bizarre,
man.
When you make a body knows like,
oh,
oh
[inaudible]
that'll be my,
all my breath.
Every breath is just that home.
And it's echoing.
So as I'm taking in my inhaler,
I'm still hearing the exhale,
echo and then home and I can I get,
I get deep.
Yeah.
I go deep into crazy train town,
crazy train woods,
the woods of the universe.
He wa well,
that's the I,
that sound is considered the original
sound vibration of the universe.
That's the sound that
all things emerge from.
That's like the basic primordial sound.
Oh boy.
It was a big bang that you went home.
Or when Bob fucking boom.
Oh,
what a shitty theory that is.
The Big Bang is the shittiest theory ever.
And I'm not a scientist and I'm clearly,
I'm retarded,
but,
and I know that there's some evidence,
supposedly that some big explosion
happened 14 billion years,
but th th th they have no
idea why everything was
smaller than the head of a pin
letting you talk.
Yeah.
And so wait a minute.
We do with it.
Everything was smaller
than the head of the,
but why was it swollen that we don't know?
We don't know.
But we do believe that there was an
infant point where the whole universal is
smaller than the head of a pin.
They don't even know why.
It's the weirdest fucking
conversation ever.
This is like someone said it best.
It might have been Mckenna,
I think Terence Mckenna said,
um,
it's as if they're asking you
just believe in magic only once.
Right?
Magic.
They,
um,
they've read recently figured out a
way to get subatomic particles to move
faster and light.
So that's what they believe
they've accomplished now.
So that,
it was just really a week ago the
scientists were saying time travel is
impossible because the speed
of light cannot be surpassed.
And then like a couple of weeks later,
these guys say they got
subatomic particles to move
faster and like time travel
was open again.
So that's the implication.
Yeah,
time travel was the big implication
because once they figured out how to an
actually mean,
it would require an
immense amount of power.
But just thinking about what powers your
cell phone today and what was like to
have those,
you know,
Apollo 11 computers when they filled an
entire rooms and they weren't nearly as
powerful as your cell
phone and your cell phone,
not even plugged in anything.
It's in your fucking pocket.
Can you explain what that,
I know they,
maybe you can cause I don't understand it.
I,
I they will blast it to
neutrinos or something.
And then it trinos where they reached
where there were supposed to reach a few
milliseconds before they should
have reached it or something.
That's a huge question.
So let's,
let's look it up on Google because
I'm not the person answers.
And also I don't think they've
totally confirmed it yet.
I think a lot of people are still saying
that there's a high likelihood for some
kind of error and they experiment a
course and while everybody's going to say
that anyone when something that crazy,
you know when someone says,
oh I figured out the time traveling bitch,
figure out how can we see your papers.
He didn't feel at that
time she was a bitch.
Yeah.
I was thinking about time travel.
If there really was a time traveler then
they could follow somebody by walking
in front of them.
Wow.
That's a,
yeah,
cause you would know where they were going
already so you could walk in front of
them on whatever.
We would have to have like a really
fucking detailed list of all the shifts
that's already gone down.
You have to see it,
you'd have to send a time pro back
first to like watch and watch the whole
world.
Observe whoever you want it
to run out of time would die.
You die of old age.
No.
If you want it,
you could send,
you could like,
it's,
you know,
if you wanted to observe like
Thomas Jefferson or something.
Right.
What'd you be?
Incredible.
Yeah.
Right.
To get real videos of
the founding fathers.
Who would you go to if you had,
if you had a just an
open ticket back in time?
Clearly the first person I visited,
his Jesus,
no,
hold on.
Jesus or Buddha or Jesus or Buddha.
That's a tough choice.
I think.
I,
I know the first human,
I want to visit the first human,
I guess
the first human you'd want
to see cave men on the field.
Yeah.
I think that if,
I mean if I had to have
a bunch of chances,
I,
that's the first thing I'd like to see.
Then I move up to Buddha
and then,
Uhm,
I dunno.
All right,
here's the,
here's what it is.
The research clearly shows that when a
total of 15,000 beams of neutrinos were
fired,
the tiny particles traveled,
the 730 kilometer,
2.43 millisecond trip,
roughly 60 nano seconds faster than light.
Wow.
That's fascinating.
Because that,
that's,
that's just,
that's period.
That's not,
they think so.
That's it.
Yeah.
By saying that this is Soren
that's putting this out,
so that's it.
So,
so they'll know Cerner's folks CRM,
look it up.
It's still the people that are
responsible for the large Hadron collider,
which is the,
the craziest scientific experiment
ever that's going on right now.
I believe it's in Switzerland,
right?
Yes.
From Sweden underground.
Fucking incredible gigantic particle
collider that is supposed to uncover this
thing called the Higgs Boson particle,
which they call a,
or excuse me,
most,
and people have corrected me on that.
Listen,
my apologies.
Boson the God particle.
Yeah.
But now they're saying that it's
95% sure that it doesn't exist.
Yeah.
Fuck.
Too Bad.
You know,
you imagine that they built this gigantic
fucking billion dollars when they
obviously finding out
a bunch of other shit.
I'll take time traveler
or some stupid particle.
Well who knows what that particle means.
They did create that
cork glue on plasma shit.
That's,
I believe it's one sugar cube was like
400 billion pounds or something fucking
crazy.
But that's what it was.
They created some incredibly
negligent will amount,
you know,
some tiny,
small,
yeah.
Don't want a lot of that shit.
Lanner right.
Did you imagine if they made
like a marble sized chocolate?
It just dropped the earth
just shot right into the
water and core like water.
The earth would just be
like a big droplet of water.
Oh,
I wonder how much weight it
would take for that to happen.
For sure.
If you had a bowling ball full
of this Gwar glue on Yasma Shit.
Yeah.
That shit would just go right through
the right to the earth of bowling ball
would have to be some
insane amount of weight.
Yeah,
it would be.
I,
yeah,
I don't know what the weight would be.
Someone should,
I don't know,
had around something.
There's that dense,
think like a fat person
and you look at it like,
think about,
um,
fat James from the container store or
fat James Lovelock chain is a great guy.
Calls himself fat James Fox.
We got off.
It's,
it's his nickname.
It's Fred James calls you up.
Hey,
it's Fred James.
Yup.
Um,
so you think about him as a human easy,
not a tall fellow,
but he's fairly heavy and you look at it,
we go,
wow,
that's a,
that's a lot of weight right there.
That's wonderful.
Now think about if he was
a cork glue on plasma,
you know what I'm saying?
I mean,
even wrap your head around that.
Yeah.
A sugar cube is 40 billion or 400
billion fucking pounds over the hell.
Yeah.
Whatever insane mean
when you say 40 billion,
400 billion.
I know that it's,
there's a big difference
in those two numbers,
but to me,
none of them even register.
I'm just making noises with my mouth.
I don't know.
Right.
40 billion means or 400 billion means.
That to me is like,
it's too abstract.
It's too big.
I'm not assimilating that.
You know,
but to think about fat James
made out of this stuff,
you can't even like,
how is that even possible that it could
be two types of matter that are both
some the so far different from each other
that they could be the same size and
one of them would be literally
the weight of the fucking earth.
Probably not that way.
Yeah.
It's,
it's insane to think about that and it's
insane to think that these people are
down there tinkering around under
Switzerland trying to make this shit.
That's what this is creepy.
Well they make only a
little tiny amounts of it.
You know,
they've,
they're,
they've got a great
sense of humor about it.
They,
they dress up like the life dude's
and they've like take pictures of them
pretending to be the
characters and halflife.
Yeah.
Cause we don't know that the video
game half life was all about scientists
cracking a hole in the universe
and the aliens come over.
Fuck everybody up.
Awesome game.
What an awesome game that is.
But dude,
I like to think about,
one thing I like to think of APP is
the large Hadron collider accident.
Like what it would look like
and like the way I see it,
it goes like this.
You're,
you're on the Internet,
you look on wherever you go,
CNN and it says fire
large Hadron collider.
That's the first thing
you see and you're like,
God that sucks.
Now there was an explosion underground.
That's it.
Then like five minutes later it's like
this fire is spreading like no fire we've
ever seen before.
Like the fires just all of a sudden
just racing through Switzerland.
No one understands why it's spreading
that fastener and like what the fuck?
And then the next thing
you think is what's that?
You're just gone.
Cause this fucking energy beam is shot
around the planet and like a millisecond
just wiped everything out.
That's,
that's how I know I've eaten too much pot.
Cause inevitably my mind will
start going to the large,
I'll start getting,
getting nervous about the
large Hadron collider.
Have you eaten too much pot today?
No.
You're okay?
Totally fine.
How much of that Cook you take?
Just a crumb.
I didn't even open.
Oh yeah,
I took a crumb.
Good move.
Yeah,
I'm not,
I,
I've,
I've fucked up so many times.
Yeah.
You know,
I'm 100% for marijuana legalization,
but I think you should at least have
to read a book or watch a documentary
before.
Eat one of those cookies.
Yes.
You don't know what the fuck you again,
I could eat a cookie.
It's just a cookie.
It's no big deal.
I'm going to eat the whole
cookie.
Those cookies are crippling sometimes.
Sometimes.
Cause you don't know what,
how many,
there's no standard dose.
Like when you get a
cookie and it says two x,
what the fuck does that mean?
You know,
two doses.
Two doses for who to x is three x is,
I don't know what this fucking,
you're using a porn system for this shit.
You're using the porn rating system.
Dude,
I had a one,
a one bite of a very small cookie.
This cookie was only like the size of us.
Not even just slightly
larger than a quarter.
Yeah,
it was a small cookie.
I took a little bite out of it.
I said,
let's just be careful.
I'll take a little bite out of it.
An hour later,
I literally,
my whole body was tangling.
I want to just lie down on the
carpet and make like carpet angels.
I was lit screen.
I mean roaring,
roaring through the tunnels of reality
clinging to the earth as it spins a
thousand miles an hour.
I was,
all I could think of is what the fuck
would happen if I took that whole cookie.
I couldn't even keep my eyes.
What would happen?
I was like this.
I was just sitting.
I was like cuddling with
myself on the couch.
I was blasted.
Meanwhile,
the phone rang and I picked up the phone.
Hello.
I was talking to a buddy line.
Yo,
what's up dude?
No,
everything's cool,
right?
Yeah,
no,
I'm just,
I'm getting some writing done.
All right man.
I'll talk to you a bye.
Click.
Oh right back into it.
I could talk on the phone like I,
I could,
I could be okay.
I was functioning.
Yeah,
but I was thinking,
what if I took that whole fucking cookie?
Okay.
Yeah.
That's funny though.
That thing you just said about
how that part of your mind,
the part of your mind that like clicks
back into know like no matter how deep
the psychedelic experiences there is a
party puts a flashlight in your eyes.
Yeah.
Like dude,
we're cool.
Everything's fine.
Yeah.
It's very strange how your mind can
do that no matter how far out you get.
It's very,
it's a,
it's a curiosity.
Like there's a story about the ROM DASS
talks about this lady car them cause she
was on orange sunshine,
which was apparently back in the
60s it was like the ultimate LSD.
It was like this legendary acid.
And she called him and said,
you know I've,
I've,
you know I've gone,
I've took too much orange sunshine.
I'm going completely insane.
I don't know what to do.
And he's like,
okay well can you put the person on who
thought that they should call me and
pick up the phone and dialed it cause
that's who I want to talk to you right
now.
Cause it's like her,
she was a logical enough to not
to dial a phone and call and talk.
She was making logical decisions.
She had just decided to allow herself
to be the crazy person for a second.
You know,
there's always,
that's,
that's what I'm saying is it's
like there's always the observer.
There's always the part of yourself that's
watching you go into whatever or the
experiences that you're going into,
whether it's a psychedelic experience,
whether it's a traumatic life experience,
there's always the part of you
that's just kind of watching.
It just depends on who you want
to identify with it at any given,
you know,
so,
so you know,
when you get angry,
easier said than done though.
When you're talking about
someone going on a bad trip.
Because when you go on a bad trip,
you could feel utterly helpless.
Right.
The crazy thing about
psychedelics is that you have to,
you have to release yourself to them.
You must submit in order to take
in the experience correctly,
you've got to submit or you got to
take doses where you have no choice.
Yes.
You know,
and those are,
that's better.
I know you said that was awesome,
but yeah,
no,
it is you that was as honest
as you could have been.
Yes.
That's a better thing because when you
have to surrender that involves like this
choice to die,
it's like it's still,
the bad trips occur and the reason why
the bad trips occurs because you're
fighting it,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
yeah.
I mean there are bad trips can occur
for a lot of different reasons.
I,
yeah.
It's quite often it's ego death.
You're desperately trying to keep
yourself from blinking out of existence.
Yeah.
You've,
your ego kicks in and does the exact
same thing that happens when someone's
dying.
Okay.
I used to,
it makes sense to you then that you know,
you would be feeling like you're
going crazy and to be terrified.
Oh no,
sure.
Isn't it the,
isn't the real problem that there's no
one to guide people on these experiences?
No.
Like really seasoned professionals that
measure the dose in a clinical setting
and like,
you know,
like,
could you imagine how much help
people could get from that sort of an
environment?
Dude,
you've helped me.
I've talked to you on the phone when I'm
way too high and you've inevitably made
me feel better just from
like talking to you,
cause I'll call it out
if I'm freaking out.
I don't remember the specific time,
but I know that I've called you and
just started talking about some terrible
idea I'd have about an imminent war.
Something like some awful thing.
I'm getting paranoid about it and
you're really good at being like,
that's not going to happen.
You're fine that everything's fine.
And it just takes that it's just
one confident person and be like,
dude,
everything's going to be really great.
You don't have to worry about
anything and you'll feel better.
So yeah,
you're right.
There needs to be these people.
Especially that's not right.
Not even
someone you know who
knows what they're doing.
That's just a friend you just
called up a friend and seem normal.
But if you were getting
dosed up by a professional,
you know what I'm saying?
Because I think,
look,
like I said,
I do think that everything
should be legal.
I mean,
I think there's horrible consequences
to make crack and heroin illegal.
And if you want to keep those illegal,
um,
you know,
I'm not gonna fight you.
I'm not going to fight your own math.
I'm not going to find,
I don't think it should
be easy to get math.
And I think the people make math for sure.
You should fucking put them in a cage.
Yeah.
You know,
some asshole.
What's,
it gives someone addictive,
some horrible fucking chemical that's
from cold syrup and shit and it just
completely fucks your world up.
But when it comes to other stuff,
when it comes to like mushrooms
or Iowasca or all these,
these things have to be
released to the public.
Totally.
They have to,
if they don't get released to public,
society suffers.
Society is more lost.
Society is a less
introspective is more plumper.
Prone to patterns.
Yeah.
It's like closing the library.
It's a type of library.
You're not like letting people
into not just a library,
but perhaps a,
a source of inspiration,
of knowledge,
of wisdom.
It might even be another
fucking life form.
You know,
so many,
um,
uh,
corrected me on Twitter the
other day about something,
but we were talking about mushrooms
being plants and it was like actually
mushrooms,
not a plan.
It's a fungus.
It's a totally different lights.
Life source,
isn't it?
Its own kingdom.
It's its own kingdom.
And not only that,
they're,
they're closer to animals
than they are to plants.
And you know,
when,
when you talk about a
giant super organisms,
the whole Pacific northwest,
apparently there's some giant mushroom
colony and the Pacific northwest,
it's all considered,
you know,
it's under the,
it's mycelium or whatever the fuck it is
considered one large organism and it's
one of the biggest organisms on the,
on the planet.
It's like a fucking
sperm whale of mushrooms.
I think it's bigger than a sperm.
I mean,
I think it's you like,
it's like,
isn't that miles or something?
Something crazy like that.
But it is a life form.
And Mckenna had this rap
about mushrooms that,
um,
not only did he think that mushrooms were
the catalysts for humans evolving from
lower primates,
but he also thought that mushrooms
came from of their planet because the,
because the fact that spores could survive
in a vacuum and it's structure of a,
of a,
what is it,
five p there's a,
it's called a Fox for a [inaudible] and
dimethyl trip and he said something like
something about that
phosphorous or positions,
the only one like it on the planet.
There's nothing like that
mushroom and the planet.
And yet it mimics human neuro chemistry.
I mean,
and,
and dimethyltryptamine is produced
in the human body and the,
and it's in the blood brain barrier and
they think it's responsible for dreams
and all that shit.
And this stuff has it in it.
I mean it is,
that is part of what it is.
And if it really did
come from another planet,
imagine if you know,
all of our ideas about intelligent
life are based on the above,
the ability to manipulate carbon,
to build the ability to
manipulate carbon matter.
But what if a mushroom is a life form
that has evolved so far that it doesn't
need a form anymore.
It doesn't need to move and the way it
gets you as you eat it and you can't kill
it,
it fucking fly through
space on an asteroid gets
knocked off of one pat planet
and travels 4 billion light years
to another one and lands there,
you know,
and it starts up a new fucking colony
and mushrooms and they grow and they grow
where people are.
They don't grow in the middle of nowhere.
They're not hard to find.
They're on grass lawns.
Lawns were people who always are.
They're always around people,
man.
There's people,
there's mushrooms.
That's a weird thing.
The idea that it's a life form a life
form from another planet that came in on
an asteroid and that that's
how theory of Panspermia that,
that that's how life is
seated throughout the unit.
What's the word?
Penn spirit.
That's cool.
Yeah.
The idea is that the universe is seeded
by asteroid impacts hitting planets and
knocking off,
you know,
um,
uh,
amino acids and the building blocks
of life and in somehow or another,
some sort of a chemical reaction with
another plan and also comments carrying
water and the water comes and in life is,
and it's,
you know,
and it goes from one planet to the other
and that's the idea is we're seated by
asteroids.
Yeah.
That,
I mean,
that idea I've heard,
I've heard Mccain has idea and it,
and when you're tripping,
it definitely does seem like you are
getting some kind of transmission from
something you're getting.
Right.
Well,
not even a transmission to me.
To me when I'm really gone,
it feels like I'm in
something or I'm a part of it,
you know,
like,
um,
it's not a transmission.
Um,
in this amount,
my,
whatever your consciousness truly
is outside of cells and fingernails,
whenever your,
your,
your inner consciousness is,
this thing took me to another place.
And so the physical body
that I exist to move around,
it literally didn't exist and
I was inside this other place.
It's an experience that's not like,
it's not like a transmission,
you know,
it's almost like more like
a chemical gateway feeling.
And you know,
we talked about this before the podcast
that it could just be your sense is
fucking with you when
you're whacked out on drugs.
It big.
It could be that your senses,
everybody sends his work the same way.
You take this whacked out drug and
everybody gets a reaction the same way.
But I don't think it is.
Um,
and even if it is,
it's more fun to think that it's
not and there's no evidence to prove
yes,
facts,
stick with it because
it's more empowering.
It's more fascinating.
I like to believe in magic.
You know,
I don't have to believe in too much magic,
but I like to believe
that mushrooms are magic.
I like to believe that DMTs magic.
I like to believe that the wheat is magic.
I really believe we,
it is magic.
It sounds stupid,
but listen,
I'm,
I'm talking about it in a silly,
utilitarian way,
in a way that's functional and easy to
use without delving too deeply into what
the wheat is.
When I smoke weed,
all the sudden I get ideas.
I smoke weed and it's shit.
Ooh,
all of a sudden I have ideas.
What is that?
If that's not magic,
I don't know what the fuck is.
All things come to you from
the burning of a plant.
He burned a plant.
You take in its essence,
west
introspective thoughts.
Start worrying about your own behavior,
studying yourself,
looking at the world differently,
thinking about,
wow,
how strange clowns are,
man,
they're just floating above us.
There's moisture in them,
right?
Where's that coming from?
Mad.
Well,
you're whacked out,
man.
You killing your brain cells,
That's your brain cells done.
That's the first time your
brain cells are dying.
As you start adding brilliant thoughts,
you remember that and this
is your brain on drugs,
the the Ag love at any point in time
to get high and debate that Guy,
the Warren drive,
that commercial guy.
No nonsense guy.
Yeah,
this is your brain.
This is your brain onto a bill.
Hicks had a great bit about,
well,
every comic at the time had
a great panel about that.
Bill Hicks had a particularly
brilliant one about that,
but how preposterous it was.
You know,
there,
you remember those commercials that came
on after nine 11 where a guy was a no
nonsense guy in a steakhouse
with a suit on eating a salad.
And his friend was like the silly
man and his friend were like,
man,
you can't tell me that.
You know,
if I smoke pot,
I'm supporting terrorism.
Yes I can.
And he's eating,
eating the lettuce.
You know why?
Because it's true.
That's a drag show.
Like a no nonsense man with his suit on.
I'm eating a salad.
I'll tell you right now,
most of the drugs that
use or put terrorism,
marijuana,
fuck man,
they're the most retarded.
There's no logic to them.
The appeal to the weakest of emotions,
the desire to be this fat
douchebag eating a steak salad,
okay?
You know,
so you know it with a
suit on and a runner.
I'm a no nonsense man.
Was Bob's always working.
That's right.
He's a disciplined business man.
Cause it's true.
Taking any nonsense,
you know it's fucking tree.
You know,
Alex is a no nonsense man,
that fucking pig in New York.
Who makes those women?
He netted.
Did you see that shit?
Crazy fucking beefy piece a shit.
There's like these two
apparently out there,
there's these two distinctions
and the police there in,
they're calling the white collar
police and the blue collar police.
The guys in the blue suits are apparently
just being policed and they're cool,
but they're these violent kind of like
a thug pigs out there who have been like
grabbing people.
You weren't doing anything.
And I saw the video of
the girls getting maced.
Did you see that video?
Yeah.
It looks like this is the girl tried to
pull down the barrier and then he just
amazes her.
Is that what happen?
No,
no,
no.
I watched it a bunch of times
and I didn't see her do that.
And if she did do that,
you can then you can't make him.
But he didn't just make her,
he makes it a Mason Mason.
He amazed a bunch of them.
Yeah.
For no reason.
And then he skis Kinda like skittered off.
Yeah,
he did.
He did.
He came in,
did it,
and then try to sneak away.
They got a picture of the son of a bitch.
It's on,
you can look at,
what's the name of that thing?
It's occupy Wall Street.
Is that what it's called?
Yeah.
On that site,
occupy Wall street.org I think
there's a picture of the guy.
They got a picture of him and they're
trying to find them because they've got
lawyers who are volunteering to help
the people get out of jail and help the
people who are like,
they've already arrested
at a hundred people
and what are they doing?
They're protesting what?
See that's they're protesting.
The idea is they're protesting the fact
that 1% of the people on the planet
control the resources and they're
going to Wall Street because that's a,
that seems to be like
the locus of all this,
like a greed.
There's great video.
There's video of like these really like
rich people sitting out on the balcony
drinking champagne and
toasting the protest or all
these like Super Richie rich
is out there just to watch and I'm like,
they're like fucking with them.
Yeah.
Kinda really?
Wow.
You know,
like there are novelty.
It's like look,
oh look at the protesters.
What I keep hearing,
I keep hearing that no one's
covering this in the mainstream news.
I keep hearing that.
But then I'm looking@bloomberg.com
and it's on there.
It's on business insider.
I think they've started covering,
covering like they have to because
people are starting to get arrested.
Yeah,
that's it.
Is that what it is?
But I don't know the real
number of people that,
that are out there right now.
I would love to,
and this is fascinating.
This is a new movement.
Yep.
And it's happening right now.
I mean,
if you're,
if you're in New York,
you could go down there.
Right now I'm bringing him a
sandwich cause they gotta be hungry,
man.
A lot of these kids,
they don't look like they don't.
They've been out there for eight days.
Nearly a hundred people have been
arrested for protesting in and around Wall
Street during what?
Some are calling the Arab
spring of the United States.
Outraged.
Oh Wow.
That's scary.
I know you think about what's going on.
These Arab countries outrage over the
way that the political and financial
worlds are managed.
Protesters calling themselves in 99% of
gathered to share their grievances with
the top 1% of America and demand change.
Well,
I don't understand why
it's illegal to protest.
I thought protesting was always legal.
Is it your,
you have to get a permit to protest and
that these people don't have permits?
Is that what it is?
I think that they,
they did get per,
I don't know.
I'm sure.
I wouldn't be surprised if there
was like they didn't have a permit.
Seems gross that you should need
to get permission to protest.
It seems like there should
be some sort of a right,
but I don't know if you should be
able to do it on someone's property.
Like if you're blocking
them fucking traffic.
Yeah.
That shit's annoying mean.
It does seem to go counter
to the idea of a protest,
which is like,
can I have your permission to protest?
You're just supposed to protest.
Yeah.
I mean,
look,
it's something I,
you know,
I support them.
They're doing something,
you know,
they're,
they're out there beating the drum.
They're letting everybody know,
hey,
we're,
we are pissed off.
But to say it,
it's like,
it's like an Arab spring
in the United States.
That's fascinating what people are saying.
I mean,
it's like people,
this whole thing of like 1% of the
fucking population having all the shit.
It's like,
it's some point that
that can't work anymore.
Like if you're on an a,
let's imagine we're on an island and one,
there's like 10 people on the island and
one person on the island has control of
all the bananas.
It's like you got to share the bananas,
man.
You gotta pass the bananas around.
I don't care how you got them.
Right.
And the idea is that you
look at the end of the day,
you're using up the earth's resources.
If you're,
especially if you're talking like
some big gigantic corporation,
you're using up a gigantic
chunk of the earth's resources,
which you know,
really in all fairness
should be distributed equally
for all the people on the
planet.
We just don't have the technology.
You had to do it.
And also a lot of the people who have the
resources would get distributed to are
fucking idiots,
right?
So that is a real problem because a
lot of people are not had because our
education system is crap.
So people have been being like brought
up through a really crappy education
system.
Not all schools are terrible,
but a lot of them,
they had these,
they have way too many kids.
How are you going to teach a
classroom of 60 fucking kids?
Many of them in like who are living
in poverty and their parents are drug
addicts.
How are you going to do that?
You'd have to be superman
to pull that off.
So it's like the year
you're dealing with like,
uh,
people who haven't been educated
and people who are hopeless.
And so the real question is,
let's imagine that all the 1% that these
people are protesting suddenly like
more like,
you know what?
We're going to distribute our wealth.
How do you do that?
Like how would you even do it anyway?
Like what's the,
how do you,
how do you solve?
I don't know.
But they're saying we
have to do something.
That's what I'm saying.
They're right.
The system is completely fucked up.
It doesn't work.
It's not,
it doesn't make sense that you,
you,
you like the whole idea
of the financial system.
You know,
the whole idea of when you started talking
about banks and economics and numbers
and manipulating things.
And then things get so weird when you
talk about like interest rates and they
talk about taxes and you talk about
the distribution of the money.
Where does the tax,
when they going,
or is it,
when you break all these numbers down,
then you realize that these
numbers only represent numbers.
They don't represent a
fucking bag of gold somewhere.
Nope.
They don't represent
anything of real value.
It's like number.
So then when someone has no fucking
$18 billion or something crazy,
and then you,
you,
you examine them and you go,
what did you do?
Well,
I moved numbers,
I move numbers around and I made billions
of dollars moving all these numbers
and buying and selling
numbers and agreeing and,
and,
and Graham Hancock's here.
Cool.
Powerful.
All right folks.
That's the end of this one.
And we'll be right back in about 15
minutes cause he's gonna eat some food,
but thank you.
Yep.